here to talk about issues raised by the
sturgis rally and other pandemic
developments is cbs news chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook john thanks
for joining us i wanted to start with
this argument that the death and
infection rates are so low such a small
percentage of our population that you
know they don't warrant mass mandates or
vaccines isn't what's at stake here the
health care
system at large i mean doctors
staff nurses ppp i mean you were telling
us it's harder now than it was a whole
year ago yeah i mean i well this last
week i have spent hours every single day
answering questions from people because
in a way it was easier psychologically a
year ago because we knew what to do we
stayed home we didn't see anybody we
just hunkered down now the questions are
can i go to a wedding can i go to a ball
game can i go to a restaurant indoors
outdoor mass no mess what about my kids
i have a trip to iceland somebody called
me back what do you tell people yeah and
i say okay first of all big picture
a year ago
to now we're a lot better now so we have
this amazing vaccine we know from the
aerosol scientists which is so important
about the importance of ventilation why
is that important well a year ago i was
wearing a mask outdoors now i know if
i'm a distance from people outdoors i'm
fine it's like infinite dilution out
there we know that masks are important
that they work they're a therapeutic so
we're different now than a year ago but
in terms of the nitty gritty of what you
do indoors it depends on where you are
and what your risk tolerance is because
if you're in a place which is hot
and you go indoors and you're vaccinated
remember that the advice back in may was
you didn't have to wear a mask right
back then delta was one percent and we
thought that if you got infected if you
did get a breakthrough infection there
wouldn't be enough virus in your nose in
order to spread it to somebody else now
it's more than 90 delta we know from the
outbreak uh in provincetown that in fact
you can get a breakthrough infection and
have enough to probably spread it to
other people and so you have to make the
decision okay
where am i if i'm at home with somebody
who is immunocompromised or somebody
under 12 who can't get vaccinated yet or
somebody who's older then i could
potentially get infected there and bring
it back to them so you know suspenders
wear the mask can we talk about that
group because right now the largest
vulnerable group is vulnerable
involuntarily right because they can't
get the vaccine that's kids under the
age of 12. when does that happen we
think that that's going to happen uh
probably sometime in september and you
know the issue of kids
we're evolutionarily wired to protect
kids right i mean a person will go into
the street and risk their life to save a
five-year-old from getting hit by a car
and who they do not know
and yet somehow
we're not all coming together and rowing
in the same direction about protecting
kids under 12. you're exactly right they
can't get the vaccine yet we have to do
extra steps in order to protect them i
think one of the other questions you
talk about extra steps is the idea of
whether you call it a supplemental or a
booster shot for the immunocompromised
where are we when we might see that as
well well the fda is not waving me off
from the idea that i floated that next
week we may get advice about people who
are immunocompromised uh whether they
should get another shot because we know
we did the story here that uh people who
are immunocompromised for example you've
had an organ transplant you're on cell
cept or some other immunosuppressive
medication and you get the vaccine you
may not have as robust an immune
response and we're showing that those
people in fact probably do need to get
another shot so stay tuned pretty quick
pretty quick pretty quickly very quickly
we got to go but the latest numbers show
that 18 of the population will not get a
vaccine under any circumstance if 18 of
the population does not get vaccinated
can covert be beat absolutely because we
we beat epidemics before there were
vaccines it was called getting infected
right i mean this is so infectious if
you don't get a vaccine two things are
going to happen you're going to get a
vaccine or you're going to get covered
those are the odds you may have more
loss of life more less life and you get
infected people who are immune and then
you have people are vaccinated and
immune doctor thanks good to see you